[Music]
all right hey listen a few
months ago
i said
you if you will
use the listener if you will email i
mean if you will
write me letters
with poems in them i guess i did a poem
about james i forgot this i did a poem
about you james and i think it was
remarkable and i asked people to mail
letters in
good god almighty you sent letters in
i've got stacks i'm like a mailman now
the guy that sits next to me ken was
like what is happening over here it's
like a it's like harry potter like that
owl just drops things down all the time
except there's no owls that's what makes
it even weirder
um but we're gonna do a mailbag here so
i'm gonna read some of the letters you
sent in i hope you
were serious
um
this one's really long i won't do this
one sorry if this was somebody's
like they really meant something they've
accepted your poem writing challenge get
ready
i'm presenting you the greatest poem of
all time here it goes
come on man
thanks heidi the poem is
james is super rad
kelly carries herself with poise
the doctor john dolone show is my
favorite fan
forever a fan that's my favorite
forever a fan of the horse noise
heidi you totally redeemed yourself
there at the end feels like a win-win
for both of us there i think we all win
kelly as always you lost all right let's
see here smoke's on a stick some of you
all sent in notes and you all need to go
to therapy now like right now
don't stop go don't collect 200 and if
you don't even know what that is you're
too young
all right here we go
hey john i accept your challenge here's
my poem obviously i can't write poems i
don't remember the stanza rhyming rules
there is no rules
and please consider a simple man by
leonard skinner for being the best song
ever written
i will take that into account thank you
so much
all right
this poem is entitled delony
delony delony he never talks baloney
told you kelly
he shows up to teach us how to love
every time i listen i feel like a
special dove
yes
when he says best song ever written
i am even more smitten is this a love
letter are you gonna kill me at the end
of this carry on brother john to help us
all have a special bond when our time is
done we will know you helped us make a
difference in so many others existence
now
go outside and play
dude
joanne
brought some smoke and you didn't even
mention james and kelly which is cool
we'll do one more this one's written
like a serial killer this poem's
entitled john this could be about a
commode or me
john are you listening
john is that a horse i hear
listen good folks five bucks stand up
move forward what does that mean john
stop counting
we are here community your people
poem for john
i'm a super fan
thank you for being you kelly and james
too good jobs all thank you
i don't think you need therapy but you
need a morning
drinks you should start drinking earlier
i don't know when you start drinking but
it should be earlier thanks to everybody
for your poems
dude these are gonna get awesome but i
need you to screen some of these holy
smokes
whoa
that might have been my favorite segment
of the whole show what's up this is
gonna be my new favorite thing on the
show
we go
hey doctor john i was listening to an
episode of your show on july 28th to the
introduction you challenged listeners to
write your poem and mail it with a stamp
i decided to check accept the challenge
here's another haiku
i wrote a poem it's bad
i've got 10 billion hours to improve
nick
nick
thank you
i'm going to be sitting in a deer stand
sometime in the middle of the winter
trying to decipher this poem in you and
your 10 billion hours
thank you nick i'm going to publish
these we're going to publish all of
these
whoa whoa